let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
when i go on a tour
of a federal building
i always make sure to take pictures
of the security stations and the
stairwells i mean
these are historical buildings for
crying out loud you want to make sure
that you get
decent
documentation
when you're taking normal tours of a
federal building you definitely want to
make sure you get documentation of the
stairwells and the security areas i mean
these are things that you take pictures
of on a normal tour
of a federal building where the day
after you take your pictures they just
might be certifying results that you
want to stop you want to know where to
get around to the building
oh
barry lowder milk
his name is his name is louder milk i
don't even know who this [ __ ] is
has anyone heard of this [ __ ] i
mean until these tours started coming up
this this news started to arise several
weeks ago he said nope
nope nope nope i'm i'm
i'm not um
i didn't give tours no that's all false
i wasn't giving and then it was oh yeah
i had family
and then it was oh yeah a bunch of
seditionists on in insurrections on
january so i gave them tours
and then yesterday [ __ ] yesterday the
wall street journal said everyone should
apologize to louder milk
and this morning the january 6 select
committee
drops a huge video
huge evidence because loudermilk says
yesterday that evidence didn't exist if
it does show it
so the select committee's like hold my
[ __ ] beer [ __ ]
hold my [ __ ] beer if you're not aware
yet
of exactly what
the january 6 select committee
is doing with these hearings i believe
that some of this evidence in this story
may be one of the reasons why we had the
hearing delayed today
think about it you want to make way for
news right like you don't want news
piled on top of news when you're trying
to get the american people to pay the
[ __ ] attention
so you don't want to pile it on top of
each other
well if they would have had the doj
witnesses today
well
this video would have been skirted
underneath the rug
and i seen some people comment why
aren't they doing this on live
television let me tell you something
this video
this video
make it viral folks that's what you do
you make it [ __ ] viral
more people are gonna see a clip
of anything in this day and age on
social media pull that [ __ ] put
it on facebook put it on tick tock put
it on your instagram if you see a post
going viral in those places
share that [ __ ]
with this video in it
this video is clear cut evidence that
louder milk
was giving tours of people who were
scoping out the [ __ ] building for the
next day
and then in the video we see the same
[ __ ] holding a flag with a
spear end on the on the end of it
saying you know who this is for we're
coming to get you
folks they were trying to not just
overthrow our government
they were going to violently overthrow
our government
and they had the help of members of
congress
and the members of congress are [ __ ]
lying about it which is not [ __ ]
surprising they are republicans
they are [ __ ] republicans they can't
help but [ __ ] just puke up lies
every day every minute
it's non-stop they can't quit
it's like heroin to them lies oh baby
gotta have more
where's my lie dealer at let's go to fox
news oan to newsmax let's listen to
tucker he'll he'll give us some of that
that lie drug
but that's what we're dealing with
i'm going to show you the [ __ ] video
of course i'm going to show you the
video of louder milk
puking up his lies that i had nothing to
do with it
and then the wall street journal post an
article
saying everyone should apologize to
barry loudermilk
yeah we're real sorry that you're a
congressman that's maybe the apology
that we need to [ __ ] make we're real
sorry
that we put ourselves in a situation
where we have a seditious [ __ ]
like you in congress
that's
we're real sorry about that
barry loudermilk better lawyer the [ __ ]
up
him eastman all the [ __ ] members of
congress who were given tours
because i don't think this is the only
member of congress that was giving tours
i think this is this is just a prelude
folks
i think they should space these hearings
out even more everyone keeps saying oh
we should do them every [ __ ] day day
after day after day
we have to let the public digest this
stuff a bit
we have to let we have to get these
clips out it's not the herd depth trial
where they're talking about jars of
cocaine and stuff
where there's videos of amber heard
possibly snorting coke on the stand that
we don't have sensational moments like
that
that the that the average public is
gonna [ __ ] be interested in and
believe you me it's going to get them
hard and it's going to get them hard to
be interested even in this clip of
louder milk
giving tours of the capital people are
taking pictures of stairwells and
hallways
and
security entrances into certain areas of
the capital yeah it's going to be
[ __ ] difficult i know it sounds like
oh my god how would anyone want to pay
attention to this they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't
that's the trouble that we have here
that's why we
we're starting to see an insurgency in
this country
it's because as normal people look away
and don't pay attention to the
insurgency
even though the insurgency is getting
smaller and smaller by the day
not paying attention to them is giving
them power
not pointing them out is giving them
power
and that's what the january 6 select
committee's job is here to do
is to point out that you [ __ ]
are being lied to
not just the people who are believing
the lies but the people who are just
like meh who cares if they believe that
who cares if they believe that the
insurrection was just a tour
just a tour of the capital they weren't
there to overthrow the government
there's a lot of folks out there that
just don't give a [ __ ]
those are the ones we gotta get this
[ __ ] in front of and it's going to be
difficult yes
they have a difficult task ahead of them
to get these clips in the front of
people
to make sure that they look they do not
look away
you folks here on this broadcast who
come listen to me yap and scream into
the microphone every day
care about this stuff
one way or the other either you [ __ ]
hate my guts
because of the [ __ ] i say or you want to
hear what i have to say
because you're you're ready to hear
someone be pissed off about this [ __ ]
not this regular media stuff where
they're like bowl sizing oh well i can't
wait to hear from from barry loudermilk
of his explanation of what happened no i
don't give a [ __ ] what his explanation
is
i could care [ __ ] less it's lies
anyways
you can damn well better bet at this
point no matter what barry loudermilk
from georgia says is a [ __ ] lie all
of it
all of it
you can you can bet on it
he number one he's a [ __ ] republican
number two he's a sitting republican
congressman number three's endorsed by
trump
number four the [ __ ] is a known
liar now just in the last few weeks
you're a known [ __ ] liar
that's it it's all the proof you need
so i don't need to hear from barry
loudermilk
other than when he's [ __ ] arraigned
on an indictment of seditious conspiracy
that's all i need to hear
is he's pleading not guilty and then
when he takes a plea deal in federal
court i'd like to see that transcript
but that's it that's it that's all i
want to hear from barry loudermilk could
give a [ __ ] less
i don't even care if the [ __ ]
committee questions the son of a [ __ ] i
mean yeah they're asking for more
information this morning based on this
video because he's [ __ ] lying
but i doubt barry loudermilk still sits
in front of the committee
i doubt it
he may get tested we may get video
testimony but see that's the thing folks
that's why we gotta stop we gotta stop
acting like the january six select
committee caters to us
they don't cater to us the information
is what they cater to the [ __ ]
evidence folks
this nonsense that somehow the [ __ ]
select committee could have been doing
this months ago is absurd
you don't know how much [ __ ] footage
they've had to go through
how much how much [ __ ] they've had how
much [ __ ] they've had to unpack here
you're talking about um the amount of
video footage that was on the capitol
lawn not not just the security cameras
that they may have easy access to i'm
talking about all the social media
footage that these [ __ ] boneheads
took of themselves committing federal
crimes
do you know how much of that [ __ ]
footage they had to go through
and then not to mention that all the
[ __ ] interviews and all the [ __ ]
that these that these seditious congress
people
have done after the fact podcast
interviews television interviews
of them saying this of them saying that
it's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] to comb
through
jesus we do a show two hours a day every
day and we can barely comb through some
of these videos
so yes these the i think i think these
select hearings these public earrings
need to be spaced
it's a good thing it's better like today
this video dropped this morning now
social media has the opportunity to
spread this around and it doesn't
interfere with more
video testimony in the public
it doesn't interfere with that they
don't pile news on top of news and we
know here from surfing the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends here on the tony
michaels podcast which by the way we air
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch and we
simulcast you the mind is touch facebook
page
but we know by surfing the tweety tweets
and the trinity trends is that it's
it's five minutes of news
and it's
gone five minutes poof and it's gone
five minutes poof and it's gone
that's what happens
in this world of social media
where we can consume little bits of news
so quickly that's not how it used to be
think about how it used to be 20 30
years ago
you had to wait
till the evening
to get some of your news
nationally
and half the time it was already tainted
by the time you got it
by right-wing talk radio how do you
think we're in the situation that we're
in now
so think about this on a scale of making
sure that americans hear this
and i'm not again i'm not talking about
the ones that are already convinced that
this this was a [ __ ] coup
most people can
look at the evidence that is available
and discern that yes these people were
trying to overthrow our constitution
they were trying to take our [ __ ]
vote away from us
but that's not who this is about
this isn't about the people that are
already convinced that this is a [ __ ]
coup
and it's an ongoing coup
we see the elections last night people
who are bound damn and determined
to not have an american constitution but
to have a fascist state
by making sure they overturn your vote
no matter how you vote especially if it
doesn't go their [ __ ] way
with some of these trump secretary
estates
we might get into that i doubt we'll
even get there see what i mean
it's difficult to even get to these
these stories
and really pick them apart the way they
need to be picked apart but loudermilk's
video this morning and his response and
that story needs to be picked apart
today
and the committee may have known that
that if there was if there was something
piled on top of the louder milk news
today this wouldn't be picked apart the
american people wouldn't pay attention
then what then what we sweep that under
the rug
we try to we try to figure out what that
was a week ago think about what the news
was a week ago for a half a second think
about it do you remember no you don't
[ __ ] remember i don't even remember
and i'm sitting here talking about it
surfing the news every single day
it's difficult
it's a shitstorm
and that is why we need to space these
hearings now i'm excited that we have a
hearing tomorrow um apparently we're
going to hear part of the pence story
is what it seems like is going to happen
tomorrow on the live coverage of the
january 6 public hearings and you guys
know that we are producing the the live
hearing for midas touch now
go over to the midas touch youtube
channel
subscribe and hit the reminder for
tomorrow's hearing it's at the very top
of their youtube page
so go over to minus touch
after the broadcast after the broadcast
right now go down and subscribe to our
channel the tony michaels podcast
but tomorrow is going to be airing
the live public hearings at the same
time
that we start our show on normal days
so noon eastern is when we're going to
start our coverage we'll start with an
hour before with commentary about the
hearing
we will play the hearing live with our
with our license midas touch cameras in
washington
our our cameras that we have for the
midas media network
and we will produce the show for you to
have the live hearing there is likely to
be a break we will try to have
commentary during the break
we'll try to bring some people in and
then after the coverage after the
hearing is over we will have a panel of
guests
that will join us to talk about the
hearing the information that the hearing
gathered
and provided us tomorrow so tomorrow
make sure you go over and set a reminder
for that hearing go to the midas touch
youtube channel
set the reminder tomorrow noon eastern
is when we start our coverage of the
public hearing
of the january 6 select committee on
june 16th and again i think that that
that
hearing is going to be mostly about the
pence side of the story i don't know if
we're going to hear from mark short
we're going to hear from a judge um the
judge that
actually tweeted out
this is not mike pence's duty
and they were advising mike pence and
his team this is not a thing
do not do not do not do this this is not
something that mike pence can do or
should do
he does not have the legal authority to
make donald trump the president
so we're going to hear from that judge i
think as a witness
the other witness that we may hear from
is mark short mark short is
mike pence's former chief of staff
mark short was standing in the parking
garage with the vice president
as the siege on the capitol continued
and they were trying to make decisions
rather mike pence was going to trust the
secret service or not and i think that
is going to be the thrust and the aim of
the questions to mark short i'm sure the
other
the other questions that i would love to
hear mark short answer is when did the
president contact the vice president if
at all that day
and if so what the [ __ ] was the
conversation
what was it we want to know
because that evidence is important to
this situation of what the president
knew and what he was not doing about it
that is important
and we've seen it on the other hearings
when we have commentators in that's been
their
question
is what what did the president know
about what was going on and what he
wasn't doing about it
because it seems there was hours and
hours
that he continued to do nothing when he
knew the siege on the capitol was
violent dangerous and deadly
so make sure to catch the hearing
tomorrow and i believe uh next week they
have the hearing set for tuesday and
thursday now here's the thing it looks
like they're not going to do these early
in the morning they're going to do them
in the afternoon um hopefully we'll get
some more prime time hearings i actually
expect
the committee to add hearings they're
supposed to have six but it looks like
if this evidence keeps piling up and
they can get these witnesses under
subpoena and get them in front of them
um that they're going to continue
with these hearings these public
hearings and they should keep it to two
a week
i'm telling you we want them two a week
so we can
have time for the meat for the social
media to do its work
it's important
that we don't pile these stories on top
of each other
but it's up to you it really is up to
you
to share it around not just on social
media but get in front of people god
damn if you got someone who doubts this
stuff
play this video that we're gonna play
today
play it
play the damn video to your your uncle
earl and your aunt edna
show them what the [ __ ] these people
were doing
this wasn't auntie for a black lives
matter you dummies this wasn't just
regular patriots going to try to save
donald trump because he won
they had [ __ ] spear headed flags
and they were ready to stop
congress from certifying so much so that
they took a reconnaissance tour
with the [ __ ] seditionist barry
loudermilk
and piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
patriots my [ __ ] ass get the [ __ ] out
of here with this [ __ ] patriots
carrying an american flag with a
spearhead on it
bragging about how they're gonna kill
someone get rid of someone
because they're just too much of a
snowflake to realize you [ __ ] lost
[ __ ] you [ __ ] lost you're a bunch of
goddamn losers
and loser milk or louder milk whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call him
doj
is about to crawl all up in his ass
i'm sure of it
ah lawyer up [ __ ] lawyer up
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right back
right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
sticking with us
i think we have some video footage for
you today uh gate sanchez is gonna have
a couple things ready for us i believe
[Music]
boy that trump fund commercial that gabe
made i
i thought about i thought about retiring
that uh
a little commercial for a while that he
made him at the trump fund but then i
couldn't because the evidence showed
that these people grifted
250 million dollars away from their
supporters which is again it's not
surprising this is not surprising
that these morons are still believing
this grift
of the election defense fund which
doesn't exist it doesn't exist
so there you have it
we're going to continue having that
commercial in the rotation
if we have another commercial break
stick around for that commercial break
because i got a a classic
commercial break that louder milk would
appreciate today
barry loudermilk
would appreciate having a pardoned
blanket
is some of your some of the viewers have
been around for a while know which which
commercial i'm talking about when i'm
talking about the the pardon blanket
so if we get a chance for another
commercial break another break we'll
we'll play that one we'll put that one
back in the rotation it seems
appropriate
oh boy oh boy oh boy
well here's the thing
we got a lot of stuff to serve today um
and and i want to get to it because i
want to get to these videos as gabe
sanchez will be joining us here in just
a few minutes um because he has some
video that he wants to play for you guys
uh we got an i think he has another what
was that you guys you guys liked the
what what what was that what was that
with gabe sanchez you like his little
segment i think we he's got another one
ready for us today uh to play and i
believe it is about january 6th but in
particular it's about peter navarro
i think it's the one that he has ready
for us he has several that he's working
on but i believe that's the report he's
gonna file today on the show live
uh as we
as as we try to uh play that that
footage
um yeah the other the other thing that i
think he has for us is possibly an
interview
about some of the coven numbers you you
guys have noticed
that some of the uh the covet infection
is rising in the country um here's the
good news is the majority of people with
the brain have been vaccinated got their
second shot and boosted um so it's not
having the effect on the health care
system with the hospitals now because of
some of those vaccinations now in some
of the areas of the country where the
vaccination rate is low it's going to
happen that way it is going to affect
these hospitals
that's just how it's going to be
um and and we're going to continue this
this
these these coveted stories as this goes
along right just because this isn't
going away it's not a thing that's just
gonna poof magically disappear like the
former guy said
we know that we're gonna live with this
for the rest of time
right but there's things you can do
about it which is like i don't know
listen to experts that know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about
so gabe sanchez actually interviewed um
an expert so we may have that one
available today as well
so i don't want to waste too much time
here but i just want to give you a few
announcements of what's coming today
so let's start the countdown and get to
the shitless roundup let's surf the
tweety tweets and trendy trends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you have reached the point where we surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
in the [ __ ] list roundup
for all you new listeners out there we
surf the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends almost every single weekday
because we air two hours every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central for two full hours we
also simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page so all the new listeners
out there make sure you click the link
to go to our youtube channel and
subscribe because you do not want to
miss a single video
also you can download this podcast
on apple spotify google every single
weekday all two hours and you can even
download our best of the week on
saturday and bonehead of the week i've
seen some of you guys asking about
boonhead of the week
in the chat here i'm trying to pay
attention to the chat there's so many
people in the chat now welcome welcome
welcome to the tony michaels podcast
that's another thing don't forget to
come over to youtube you can get in the
super chat if you don't know what the
super chat is come on over to youtube
and that the folks in the chat will
explain what the super chat is
so go ahead and subscribe to that here's
what bonehead of the week is because
everyone's asking who's gonna be the
bonehead of the week god we got a lot of
contenders this week and i'm sure
tomorrow will produce more boneheads
because think about tomorrow
tomorrow we're going to have the entire
hearing
so surely there's going to be some
boneheads that emerge from that
absolutely there'll be boneheads emerged
from that
so new listeners here's what we do we
put out a poll every single every single
week where you vote we put it out on
youtube and twitter that's another
reason why you want to subscribe to our
podcast over on youtube
just type in the johnny michaels podcast
you'll find it over there you also want
us
to subscribe to at tonymichaelspot on
twitter follow us on twitter
because the poll is over there as well
where you can vote for bonehead of the
week
we nominate three contestants for bone
end of the week and you vote
and on friday in the second hour every
week we break down your vote for
bonehead of the week and a bonehead
breakdown
and then we post that portion of the
show that segment on sunday on all
the directories wherever you find your
podcast so we actually publish
here at the tony michaels podcast seven
days a week
over on apple spotify google or your
favorite
your favorite
directory so go ahead and subscribe to
your favorite director the tony michaels
podcast
boy do we need to get to the tweets and
trend trends today
i think i'm gonna wait for gabe to go
over this uh lower milk video
um but we can look at some of these
tweets about it let me make this a
little bigger
uh murder mueller she wrote
writes new ladder milk's family tourist
we're snapping photos of tunnels and
stairwells in a building
listed in the 1776 returns plan found
ontario
it was still the plan on january 6.
this is important because kyle cheney is
reporting here surveillance footage
shows members of representative lower
milk's tour group photographing
nondescript stairwells hallways and
security checkpoints
one of the group members later recorded
a threatening january 6 message aimed at
democrats and we're going to watch that
video
where they're threatening democrats
um this is this is wild [ __ ] folks and
the reason why it's wild [ __ ] is because
loudermilk has been [ __ ] lying about
this for weeks and he keeps moving the
goalposts which is not surprising with
the republicans that's what they're the
best at
uh let's see what what now
i had another there's the video of
loudermilk
um of course on a trader news network
right this is not surprising either that
these people are going and they're lying
to their constituents they're lying to
their base because the tail is wagging
the dog and it has been for a long time
so the dog has to go yap at the tail
to tell them no no no we'll keep chasing
you keep wagging us we'll keep chasing
you
so they gotta go on these trader news
cable news networks
to spread their [ __ ] lies
because what else are you gonna do they
can't lie to us we know now we know the
truth so they got to go to lie the
people that won't that won't look
you won't look away but there's a lot of
people that are looking away at the
evidence of these january 6th select
hearings
and barry loudermilk is trying to go
get their support
hit me a [ __ ] break here's some news
scott mcfarlane reports no u.s house
january 6 committee hearing today but
there is another hearing a court hearing
in criminal contempt
uh excuse me criminal contempt of
congress case
against scabby steve that's my word
scabby scabby steve bannon for defying
committee subpoena at 10 am
so this hearing is is ongoing
here's scabby steve out in front of the
courthouse
nasty sons of [ __ ] um there was also
another
uh tweet that scott had about this let
me see if i can find this here real
quick about see yeah here's here's
here's uh
scabby steve
here scott mcfarlane says the ratings
quote unquote
steve bannon outside the courthouse just
now said the january 6
committee is totally irrelevant the
ratings stink these guys are still
focused on how many people are watching
what
they're like oh it can't be true no
one's looking at it
the [ __ ] are you no one the facts don't
and facts don't give a [ __ ] if you look
at them or not
like the facts don't care if you [ __ ]
believe them or not the facts don't care
if you view them on tv or not the facts
don't give a [ __ ] if you spread them
around social media or not they don't
give a [ __ ]
they just are facts that's just what
they are
and that's why they're gaslighting their
their [ __ ] supporters
uh you know that steve bannon has been
losing his goddamn mind
over on his podcast over on his trader
tv network
the last few weeks um absolutely
monkers
batshit crazy stuff these this is the
video the january 6 committee had
released we'll watch that soon
um and here's some pictures so here's
kyle chaney's reporting he said just in
select committee releases new details of
loudermilk's tour showing the actual
evidence of the
of the guest
photographing tunnels hallways and other
details of the complex that the
committee says are not typical of
interest a tours
so here is and we're going to watch the
video but here's a couple uh shots of
these folks there you see now you'll see
this guy's face in the actual in the
actual video
um here is um here's another video of
these people taking pictures of what
seems to be inside of a lobby or
security area
as if this is some kind of
you know a part of a museum part of the
the [ __ ] tour
people normally take pictures of like
the the elegance of the building
in the rotundas outside in the
decorative parts of the buildings
not not these security checkpoints not
these hallways and these stairwells
i mean unless it's some kind of
ornamental stairwell out in a rotunda
but not a stairwell leading to
congressional offices
this is really boneheaded stuff to think
that oh it was just a tour
um so kyle has a couple pictures here
of those of those screenshots from some
of those videos and the tiles that the
january 6 select committee has released
um here's here's the january 6 select
committee um letter to loudermilk
this is on their official twitter
and you should go follow this twitter
account at january 6 committee because
they have been
they've been retweeting some of those
clips that they have fresh from their
hearings but also they've been releasing
these clips that we see outside the
hearings
over there as well there's one from liz
chaney
yesterday
um with one of trump's white house
attorneys which i think we'll go watch
that one here
january 6 committee's account says here
the select committee reviews requests
for information
from representative
a letter to loudermilk chairman benny
thompson underscored the need to gather
more information about certain
individuals who were part of the tour
through the capitol complex on january
5th 2021 and again here is the copy of
the letter that was sent from the
january 6 select committee
uh under the chairman benny thompson
he's the one who signed and sent this
letter
to the con his
his colleague in congress
representative loudermilk barry
loudermilk from georgia and i believe
he's uh yes he's from the 11th
congressional district
in georgia
so there's the letter let's go check out
the letter read the letter
um that benny thompson wrote to his
colleague and seditious tour tour guide
this ladder mick ladder milk secret
seditious tours that's a [ __ ]
mouthful
that is a [ __ ] mouthful
uh let's go down i i like this tweet
this doesn't have anything to do
with with january 6 but becca lewis had
he did this i laughed for like 10
minutes about this son of a [ __ ] last
night
she says i literally cannot think of a
single human who is less equipped to
answer this question you guys know that
matt walsh has a film called
what is a woman what is a woman
as if these [ __ ] can't figure
out what a woman is it's okay
matt ben shapiro and tucker carl all you
[ __ ] rubes out there all you in cells
who can't get their wife's [ __ ] wet
and that's not me saying that that's
that's been shapiro's thing that ben
shapiro had a problem about getting his
wife's [ __ ] wet i'm just saying the
facts
ben shapiro has the
what is a woman on his twitter that's
his that's his uh
because the daily wire put this out
right everyone knows that bin shapiro
runs a daily wire matt walsh and him or
a bunch of [ __ ] you know goofballs
these [ __ ] rubes no one would [ __ ]
these people in the first place like
george carlin said have you ever noticed
that that the people who are against
abortion are people you wouldn't want to
[ __ ] in the first place
it's the same thing that goes with this
what is a woman if anyone's [ __ ] all
caught up in someone else's genitalia or
what gender they want to identify of or
what bathroom they go into these [ __ ]
crepazoids like ben shapiro matt walsh
have you ever noticed that these people
that are absolutely obsessed with other
people what gender they identify of
couldn't get [ __ ] in the first place
exactly and i agree with becca here i
literally cannot think of a single human
who is less equipped to answer this
question what is a woman than ben
shapiro
thank you for your thank you for your
tweet oh my god
and i think that's why one reason why
ben shapiro was
was trending but there's another video
where he's he's being just such a
[ __ ] bigot
such a [ __ ] bigot
when it comes to these these issues
here oh no this is the hershman video
okay now eric hershman says no [ __ ] to
give for john eastman but this is the
end of the video that i said that the
january 6th select committee released
um with liz chaney and i believe i have
that somewhere here on my feed
can we find this on the feed there's
there's steve bannon freaking out we
played that yesterday
and you know what let's just play this
hershman part of it because i think it's
important
i think it's important and the reason
why is because the liz cheney part is
cool but let's listen to this
uh white house attorney hershman
talk about john eastman in a phone call
that john eastman made to hershman
and hershman tells him to [ __ ] off
basically he has no [ __ ] to give with
easement let's listen he's been i don't
remember why he called me and he or he
texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
ask me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
uh
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right
he said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
now scream i said i don't want to hear
any other effing words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
and actually
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm gonna give you
the best free legal advice you're ever
getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're gonna need it
and that
and that is the
the absolute slam dunk
because even the white house attorneys
the attorneys in the white house
who around these [ __ ]
are going you people are committing
crimes you're gonna need a criminal
attorney
this is an attorney
telling this to another attorney
saying you need to get you an attorney
are you following that
this is one of the this is one of the
top white house attorneys
telling donald trump's attorney who's
trying to to develop a plan
to overthrow the constitution of the
united states john eastman
and here this attorney is telling the
other attorney get you a [ __ ]
attorney you're gonna need it this is
absolutely bonkers now i want to point
out in this
video but first i want to bring in um
gabe sanchez
gabe how are you this morning i'm good
how are you have you watched this clip
that i'm talking about here
is this the one that released yesterday
yeah well
they're like
other than uh
uh orderly transition and then at the
end he says you better get you a [ __ ]
lawyer um the funniest part is and a lot
of people are
we even goofed on this background
where what the what the [ __ ] is this i
know that's a panda right yeah that's a
it's yeah it's a well rachel said it was
a panda so there's that and then there's
this bat that says justice on it and
then there are these metal things that
appear to be like these
almost chrome helmet right yeah like
like yeah this like chrome silver hair
piece what the [ __ ] are those i don't
know it's like are they are these bats
like meant to bash in like those like he
bashed in those heads and those were the
trophies
i don't i have no idea well if you look
really closely it looks like eastman's
blood is on that justice bat if you look
re i mean if we zoom in enhancing rotate
right hand zoom yeah we'll get prop i
mean isn't it
it is absolutely batshit crazy that
donald this is the day after the
insurrection right right the day after
and the lawyers are sitting in the white
house john eastman can't get a hold of
anyone you know that's kind of the story
here from hirschmann he can't get a hold
of anyone so he finally gets a hold of
hirshman here and it sounds like
hershman's like i don't know if he
emailed me or texts me to call him he's
like i'm not sure exactly how i got on
the phone with him but he remembers the
conversation
vividly right he's like look you [ __ ]
bonehead lawyer up you committed crimes
yeah that's a i mean that's a pretty big
conversation you probably want to
remember and either he you know
had the foresight to be like okay you
guys are doing something crazy here and
i don't want any part of it
and or
he also was like
this is definitely gonna come back and
bite us in the ass so i'm going to
make sure i remember
me saying exactly that you better get a
defense attorney exactly because these
these are the lawyers that are in the
white house in the room when these
people are talking about [ __ ]
committing federal crimes right i mean
that's what bill barr was testifying to
he's like look
i tried to convince the president that
it was all [ __ ] but he continued
with this plan
to try to make himself the president
when he didn't win and i wanted no part
of it and the reason why is because bill
barr's like look i'm willing to commit
crimes but not obvious ones that are
going to put me in federal prison right
right like i'm willing to do some shady
stuff right but not that shady of stuff
when we're in the gray area and i can
kind of explain it away in a federal
court and get out of an indictment but
when you're trying to overthrow the
constitution right out in the open it's
really difficult
it's really [ __ ] difficult to walk
away from that i think you're right i
think hirschmann
in his phone call after january 6 to
eastman that's probably why he actually
talked to him and documented it right
to show that hey i think these people
committed crimes and i was telling them
the lawyer up
not maybe as evidence that they should
lawyer up but as evidence of like hey i
was on the opposite of the side that
they are on right yeah it's definitely
one of those things that you write down
and you're like
kind of got a feeling this is going to
come back for me right and if it does
i need to have my ass protected you know
this is this louder milk stuff that the
the the interviews and stuff that he's
given and some of the statements that
he's made over the last few weeks i want
to i want to thank midas uh lisa here
she in the super chat i really
appreciate it um midas lisa has been
here from the beginning she's been with
the podcast and the fan for a long time
we appreciate midas leah and midas ken
her adversary in the chat
[Laughter]
always in the chat with those two so
thanks for joining us but this louder
milk thing man this story and then
yesterday we had the wall street journal
saying everyone should apologize to
loudermilk and the january six companies
like eh i don't think so [ __ ] this
morning when they released this tape
well i mean was that an op-ed in in wall
street journal well but it it does it
really does it really matter because i
think people know that this tape was
going to drop i think what what they
were trying i mean this is all this fox
news stuff trying to yeah well i just
did i just didn't know if this was
actually like you know if it was just an
op-ed which obviously the wall street
journal is notorious not only is it
owned by murdoch but also op-eds wait
wait wait checked wait who's murdoch
who's this murdock you speak of he's
this guy his name is robert murdock
is this the same fox news that tucker
carlson has been saying that no one's
watching the january 6 select committee
trying to trying to convince people not
to watch it by telling him lies that
people aren't watching it right that
would be the that would be the worst one
yeah even even the same like the same
guy um like steve bannon and you know
tucker carlson and steve bannon saying
all the ratings suck
yeah yeah yeah the the ones that you
know uh is more of an entertainment
network kind of cable news situation
that is owned by rupert murdoch and so
he owns other things as well as wall
street journal he actually uh took over
the wall street journal
during
the
um
when uh
theronos was going through their whole
legal issue because he bought it and
then they were the ones who were
investigating that situation
sounds like thanos why do these people
why when we start digging in does these
people sound like evil villains from
superhero movies yeah yeah i mean we
have roger stone who looks
exactly like a villain steve bannon
looks like one i mean this it just you
can't yeah speaking of steve bannon i
mentioned him in a
in my new latest
what was that oh yeah yeah you had that
today did you um go ahead and um
put that in the drive so i can download
it so that uh i can play it on my end
yeah if you would and just that just
but send me the link in the private chat
and i'll download
after we go through the louder milk um
thank you claudia she said she's a first
time viewer watched on john's show i'm
i'm thinking that you you found us on
stuttering john now we we love to go on
stuttering john's show
over there so go yeah oh we love we love
john we love john we love goofing on
john we we love uh joining john
john's a good guy john goes over there
and he he does he does a lot of work as
far as getting some people on and asking
them some questions that the average joe
would want to ask
a question of someone like a congress
person just having a beer so go check
out
check out stuttering uh stuttering
john's podcast we can you can actually
find our appearances
on our youtube channel so go subscribe
to our youtube channel there's a
playlist down at the bottom
for me and gabe and our appearances on
john's show so thank you claudia thank
you very much for joining us
so
back to this louder milk thing and i
know the wall street journal is one
component of it but here's the thing is
there is an actual video of ladder milk
himself
oh no i didn't do this the capitol
police have exonerated me
and then there's no evidence of this
it's basically like uh just because we
didn't talk about you yet doesn't mean
you're exonerated right
right it's like the whole you know uh
lauren bobert tour that we've heard
rumors about
i guarantee there was footage of that
that we will see i mean these people are
giving tours
without any sort of like oh yeah i'm
gonna be totally fine no big deal i'm
gonna get away with this and let people
take photos record the the actual layout
of the building so they know where to go
right and where to go left where to go
up more to go down you know i actually
alluded to this in in the opening in the
monologue here
that maybe maybe this louder milk thing
because he was the first one to really
lie about it and have all this [ __ ]
with the with the wall street journal
and this interview that we're about to
watch that this is a signal not just a
louder milk but the letter that benny
thompson wrote and all and this
releasing this video is a signal to
those members of congress that also did
this and also may have
we're in the pardon line
uh we know there's a pardon line um and
i actually i queued up the great
commercial that you did pardon blankets
so everyone who knows barton plugging
maybe we'll go to commercial so everyone
can watch that it's totally relevant in
today's news yeah but um
this video here with barry loudermilk
really does spell out
how much of a [ __ ] liar this guy is
and and the reason why i i also i also
wonder if
they know these people are going to say
asinine things and try to be like i'm
totally you know i mean committee
well what i'm wondering is if they're
one if they're waiting they're just
waiting for these people to say
something thinking that these hearings
have begun and they haven't been
mentioned and they're totally you know
like oh i'm i'm i'm out scouts free you
know all this stuff and they're like
cool release tape number 17
right right because because locker in
the other day when when bill steffen uh
didn't show up have we have we seen a
baby yet proof of a baby i'm just i'm
seeing a baby okay well anyway i can
look at let's see yeah see if you can
look that up anyways um bill stephen
didn't wasn't able to make the hearing
the other day because he had a really
good excuse that committee said um and
and what lochran did
when she was
ticking through his testimony was
pulling clips she's like clip this clip
that clip this she was giving the clip
numbers as she was going through
um the actual presentation and letting
bill steffen in the eclipse tell us what
he was going to tell us uh in live
testimony but you're saying that they
have these clips ready right and i
believe they have i mean like i believe
all of these clips are catalogued and
ready to go based on either probably if
they had like a matrix it would be two
things one who the person is and what
the event it's centered around right
right what the topic they're discussing
with the thing that they're doing
whatever they that they're ready to go
when they say
okay loudermixel said he wasn't given
any tours great we've got lottery yeah
yeah exactly like as soon as they say
this then the january 6 says all right
great let's prep this this tape i'm
ready
to do that exactly i think they're just
pulling from like though i would assume
those are the two kind of
filters that they have going on which is
who the person is and what the event or
like the situation was and that's just
storytelling right that's good
storytelling because you're having
you're having someone go out and say
[ __ ] like we're gonna watch this [ __ ]
seditious bastard berry louder milk here
um you know spout lies out of his mouth
and then as soon as the that story is
told
and
the select committee's like nope this is
the actual story [ __ ] boom and then and
then let social media and let the
country do what they do and tell the
story to each other right that oh this
ladder milk's a [ __ ] liar well if
loudermilk's a liar and he can't be
trusted well the new elves can't be
trusted right right is it only louder
milk or are there others but let's
listen
to larry lyre loser loudermilk here they
claim to have evidence that they don't
have if they have evidence it's evidence
that the capitol police have and i can
tell you they don't have evidence
because what they're claiming never
happened
this seems
this was yesterday this was yesterday
apparently
that he was on uh this trader cable tv
network here
and and this morning this morning the
january 6 committee's like hold my
whiskey i mean they weren't they're not
even drinking here anymore
can anyone let me know what the whiplash
on loudermilk is like is he in the er
right now right or like where is he
because i can't imagine he is uh
willing to go in public and try to
double down on that no i think he will i
totally think he will gabe because i
actually believe that he's sitting here
knowing that this evidence exists he's
remember who he's talking to here right
he's not talking to the to the to the
american public on a national tv show
that's that's broadcasted on a tv
network he's talking to a bunch of
[ __ ] fascists who want to hear this
type of [ __ ] who want to hear him say
these lies and the reason why he's
saying it is because i think loudermilk
knew they had this tape i think
loudermilk knew that they were going to
[ __ ] release this [ __ ] well i mean
it's pretty crazy unless he was i don't
know i mean there is that moment of like
you would assume that the capital
totally had
footage and things that were still
running right even even though during
the pandemic the capital was shut down
for public tours you would still assume
that that the
um
that the cameras were still running and
surveillance and footage from the actual
security was still happening right you
wouldn't just shut it down because the
pandemic was happening
or
he really is that dumb i don't know like
you know he's maybe trying to act so
confident and say all right you know
they'll then they can never prove it
even though i'm on tape or he's like
no they they shut that stuff down the
capital was shut down no one can go in
like i don't know like that's got i
gotta i gotta look at that and say
are you really that dumb maybe i don't
know well again i don't think i don't
think he's that dumb i think he's
counting on the people he's talking to
here right in this interview to be that
dumb because listen to the end here they
claim to have evidence that they don't
have if they have evidence it's evidence
that the capitol police have and i can
tell you they don't have evidence
because what they're claiming never
happened so there it is again
but here is here let's go to let's go to
the quote-unquote evidence that they
don't have
because
they do have it and the problem is is
that this isn't like
um some weird account somewhere took
this video off of
some social media site or something like
that this is actual footage from inside
the capital in the security cams and
this is actual footage of these people
taking pictures because gabe when you go
on a tour of a federal building the
things you take pictures of are like
stairwells and doorways and security
areas right and i definitely want to
make documentation i mean i would want
to measure the distance between one
exit door and the stairway
to the next exit door right i don't know
possibly well i mean just in case of a
fire you know you never know where i
don't happen exactly you never know
what's going to happen in these
situations but here is the january 6
select committee's video about mr
loudermilk that was paired together this
morning with the letter from benny
thompson requesting more information
about this video let's listen
actually you know what i'm going to read
along here it says the january 6 20 i
thought it was something here but
january 6 2021 a man recorded
maybe a man recorded
a companion as they walked to the trump
jesus rally
uh the previous day on january 5th the
same man was part of a tour of the
capital complex led
representative barry loudermilk
it has begun
here at the washington monument
washington d.c
say hello to facebook
hey what's going on man glad to be here
bro this is our fearless leader
now pay attention here because this is
very important what this [ __ ]
bonehead says this is their fearless
leader now obviously he doesn't want to
be seen because he's in all camouflage
so he thinks he's invisible here even in
front i mean i can't see him on the
video i can't either
nothing i just see a flag i just see a
flag that's waving it's crazy they
literally it was during covet that this
happened they all could have face masks
on hiding their identities like the
patriot front try tries to do they
didn't they couldn't even figure that
[ __ ] out and they're recording
themselves now watch what he says about
the [ __ ] flagpole and the end of it
watch what he says about the flagpole
being a weapon
check out my flag i made guys see it
there you go baby that's from a certain
person that's right that's what
somebody's somebody special
so there he is saying that his flagpole
is a weapon and this [ __ ] nonsense
that oh this wasn't an armed
insurrection bull
[ __ ] [ __ ] here's the evidence that
you need right here to know that this
was an arms insurrection this person
actually made he manufactured this
flagpole to have a spear end on it for a
certain person continue to listen body
special
after trump's speech the man walked
towards the capitol and made remarks
about members of congress
all right
we are basically at the capitol
with
probably close to two million
true american patriots
the delusion is very deep with these
people
like
tony they have to they absolutely have
no concept of time of social media what
they're actually doing by recording this
and that they have no idea that they
were because they somewhere this guy was
told that two million people were there
right right and he looks and goes
totally two billion two million i got
two i got two million
i mean this is what happens when you ban
math tony i mean this is the group of
people who want to take away math
because of crt they couldn't solve the
inequality and now they want to take
away the ability to count and this is
what you get people who say
yeah that looks like two million yeah i
mean
look i'm no mathematician but if i had
to put my money on it like this is one
of those like
jelly bean counting games i think
there's about two million people in this
batch it's like how many two picks are
in the jar type thing right exactly like
oh my god two big did i win did i win
yeah you won yourself a jail sentence so
i mean i mean really honestly there was
a lot of [ __ ] there was a lot of
traders there that day right there was a
lot of people claiming to be patriots
that were trying to overthrow the
government rather they realized it or
not there was a lot of them and the
other thing too is he says near the
capitol of course they are near the
capitol grounds here uh but i think this
video that he's trying to take here is
to show that the crowd is big
but it's definitely not it's definitely
not two million
did you see you see him panning around
yeah that's a lot of times mainly from
constitution avenue
totally two mile routes in uh-huh
maybe that's it maybe they're all on
camouflage and we just can't see them
gabe yeah they're all in camouflage we
just can't [ __ ] see them i told you i
mean
what i see is a bunch of just waving
don't tread on me flags and american
flags
and maga flags and trump 2020 no more
[ __ ] flags
and
you know that's what i see i see two
million invisible patriots right the
real
foot soldiers you know right well you
know
this is the this is the other thing i
guess i want to point out with this
boneheaded type [ __ ]
is barry loudermilk was giving this
[ __ ] [ __ ] a tour of the capital to
make sure he knew where to go up what
stairwell's down what hallways what the
security areas look like apparently well
i'm glad that he got a cheat sheet for
how to go into the capitol i mean
because it seems like that group really
needed it you know right okay listen so
there's a thing called a door
you're gonna want to open the door okay
so you smash through the window okay
that's fine all right so next you're
gonna want to go down the hall you
smeared [ __ ] on the walls okay all right
all right oh my god this is doom like
that's the watching it live he's like i
literally gave them a step by step they
recorded it they wrote it down and this
is how they got into the building
this is what they did inside of the
building it's crazy it's crazy let's
let's finish here because the good part
comes
at the end where they show the actual
evidence of this fool
who like barry loudermilk trusted
with the with the idea that they would
go into the capital and stop the
certification
here's where he starts naming folks
battler
and these photos
that are up on the screen or photos they
took durian we're coming in like white
on rice
for pelosi
nadler
schumer
even you aoc
so white on rice that's really like not
exactly how it's normally used um yeah
that's not normally
like uh white on rice and a paper plate
and a snow storm like that's not really
exactly how it's used most of the time
it almost sounds like he's trying to
make a reference to the people that are
and all the invisible two million people
that are there the color of their skin
maybe i don't know what the [ __ ] right
there because i've never heard the white
on rice thing be used in that way before
i don't know you know what i'm expecting
now like there was 2 000 mules i want a
documentary to be made by
dinashi souza called two million
patriots
two two million fakery
patriots
oh my god these [ __ ] boneheads we're
coming to take you out
oh pull you out by your hair
sounds like a threat sounds like about
that
okay that was directed you might as well
make yourself another appointment
oh he's making a hair appointment joke
you're gonna need a sign up on top of
that bald head
oh okay saying he's gonna rip her hair
out as well yeah yeah yeah and then he's
saying you gotta go to the salon because
there's that whole thing about she went
to the salon sf thing during kovid
and uh right but this is the thing here
is he's recording all why is he yeah
like no man
the same people that are were live
streaming and posting after the fact or
wearing their work badges and then
wondering how in the [ __ ] the fbi found
them and they're like
because you said your name on video and
then posted it to your facebook that has
your whole family and your town that you
live in
and to make it even easier you had the
[ __ ] local factory you work at that
said what your position was like these
are all these dumb asses who are like
fbi big brother ain't going to get me
but then you willingly post that [ __ ]
online like no you haven't
you even had the olympic swimmer wearing
his [ __ ] jacket oh know yeah i mean
like these people are like
they're like oh the big government's too
big big brother's coming after me it's
like look big brother didn't really need
to do any work you gave big brother all
of the evidence he needed and then he
just opened up the phone and said oh
yeah that's that's definitely you okay
right i don't understand i don't
understand brad posted here in the chat
tomorrow at 1 p.m eastern uh here's the
thing uh the the hearing was postponed
today for all you listening it was
postponed today until tomorrow but we're
going to do live coverage on the midas
touch youtube channel for the midas
media network tomorrow live coverage an
hour before the hearing so join us there
at noon eastern 11 central
uh nine pacific join us over on the
midas touch youtube channel we will be
carrying the coverage of the hearing
live for all you listening let's finish
and let's watch the tour part of this
video
the tour the man took photos of hallways
tunnels and staircases within the
capital complex the video says
and obviously it's very quiet here
because this is security footage but for
you listening this there is the man um
taking a video
of the stairwell now they're taking
pictures of the security checkpoint
is you know which is a normal historical
photo that you want
and now they're taking pictures of
hallways
um the funny part is if someone comes
around the corner goes oh they're taking
pictures here uh oh no no you're good
you're good yeah it just directs it goes
you're yep cool like nobody nobody
questioned now here is here is the video
go go ahead and i'll explain what i was
gonna say the only person that i
remember questioning was uh
uh is what's-her-face
u.s representative
mikey cheryl she's a democrat from new
jersey
she was walking through and i actually
made a video
i'm gonna retweet it right now
uh of lauren bober giving a tour right
and these were different and again like
i made you know i made this video let's
see the original one i made in october
of 2021 after some details came out and
then i began to you know connect the
dots
and
uh or actually maybe before that but um
lauren goldberg gave it to her which i'm
sure we have video evidence of
and you know it's like who gave her
access and who was the one behind it and
then you have louder male killer who's
you know giving a tour but the thing is
the building was shut down to do to
covet no one was supposed to have access
that wasn't right
because they shut down what would be
normal tours right exactly
um
mj says go back tony who walked out of
that office before i go back here if you
look here this appears to be this
gentleman pointing here down the hallway
or past the security area this appears
to be a congress member
maybe just maybe it's louder milk um but
i i do want to go back here and mj's
saying someone walked out of an office
um is it is that the guy you're talking
about there are these the are these the
people you're talking about no no no
that's not the same one mikey cheryl's
is a woman or it might be mickey cherry
well well mj was saying walked out of an
office is is this the one you're talking
about mg
oh yeah oh uh she's asking if i think it
this gentleman in the blue oh is that
gates no that's not gates is she's
saying is that is that gets met gets and
i don't i don't believe that that's
magnets i don't think so that guy looks
a little too tubby matt gatz does
probably way too much coke and heroin to
be that chubby um i'm just you know
pointing that out yeah i might you know
i don't think so i don't know who that
is but i don't think it's matt gates
well i i think i think um
these people who are not their faces
blurred or not blurred because they're
wearing face masks because we notice the
rest of these people in this video have
their faces
blurred you'll even notice there's a
child in this video
um and now you gotta start them out
young you know all right and there's
also some red maga hats here as well but
let's play let's continue to play this
video again pay attention i'm gonna back
it up a bit here pay attention to when
he's taking a picture he's like oh no no
you're good you're good i got a picture
i got a picture of the little hallway
there yeah like what the [ __ ] are you
taking a picture of here
the intersection between two hallways
that might lead down oh did i ruin it
for you sorry i'll get out of the way
i'll get another one all right it's got
a flash can you can you take a
screenshot and zoom in on that sign
behind those people yeah underneath that
and see what that sign says i want to
know what that sign says above the uh
the lucky for you i downloaded this
video this morning oh my god look at
this guy look at this guy he's probably
going to use it and what was that i'm
sure he would i'm sure yeah yeah i'm
sure which we're going to get to an
episode of uh what was that with gabe
sanchez here in just a minute as soon as
we go through this ladder milk stuff but
if you if you continue here at the
footage of course he's got the picture
here it appears to be louder milk here
explaining to people in red maga hats
you can't see the person behind him but
you can see what looks like a gentleman
and like i don't know like a [ __ ]
sweatshirt and a and a red magazine
khakis right jesus christ is this is is
this the [ __ ] just a uniform of these
people oh my god but he's pointing down
the hallway past the security station
here
and it's very unclear at this point
where this security station is and maybe
maybe the january 6 select committee
will give us a better idea of where
these positions are that they're taking
pictures of because i think that's
relevant that's why i want to see what
that sign says behind that behind that
mofo um but here here you see him
talking about down there down there down
there you know i don't know exactly what
they're saying but here um here they
come down um an escalator here
and they're walking through a security
station and he's explaining the security
station for him it looks like so and
that's where the video ends again this
is all capital police uh
surveillance
so if you guys are listening
on the pod directories because you can't
see the video you have to come over to
twitter
and go either to our pages um we've got
it
we've got it retweeted there or go to
the january 6 official page on twitter
and you'll be able to find this video um
of of loudermilk so it looks like it
says long worth
long worth long worth and
so it's giving a wing or or maybe that's
a hearing room or something let me see
if i
longworth that's like typing along with
the capitol building see this this is
where it has begun this is what we're
doing here folks we are we are um
we are investigating reporting right
here live on the air
uh okay so there is the longworth
uh house office building is one of the
five buildings used by the united states
house of representative it's located on
the south
side of the capitol bounded by
independence avenue new jersey avenue c
street southeast in south capitol street
in southeast washington now the other
one i think it says raymond
like r-a-y-m-a-n so what i'm going to do
now is now that we've identified that
it's a building
we'll say
house
office buildings
washington bc uh rayburn
yeah so it's longworth and rayburn is
giving you directions to another
building now to be fair um i believe and
i i'm not an expert on this but i
believe there's
there's tunnels that connect some of
these buildings that go underneath yeah
so the capitol complex is not just the
capitol building itself there's several
buildings that are close by and some of
them i believe are connected by tunnels
now that may be some of the where
they're walking which why why would
why would louder milk
why would he
be giving tours through the tunnels that
connect the capital complex instead of i
don't know like the rotunda and the
historical part of the capital i mean
this is really well the other thing
[ __ ] the other did not know not to
know exactly what's going on the other
thing too is if you wanted to figure out
who these people were then you would go
back and say well they were assuming
they were coming from their office
possibly you would say
it would have to be coming from one of
those things now barry loudermilk
actually works in the rayburn house
office building that's one thing so does
elise stefanik
uh
let's see who else
oh [ __ ] their their congressional
offices are in that yeah so they've got
them split up in these buildings and so
that's how you would get there right so
the um you know because again like the
tunnels you know whether they're for
like security or whether for you know in
chicago milwaukee minneapolis
new york we all have these things called
pedways and they're ways where you can
get between buildings or underneath
buildings to subways
as just a means of getting around
especially during the winter so i
wouldn't be surprised if these
passageways were either one just a
secure way to get from one building to
the other but also as it means to not
have to go outside and then go back in
especially during winter or whether it's
like raining or just like right very
hard weather it it it helps to impede
movement around the complex right when
they're trying to keep schedules because
there's voting that goes on and when
they ring the bell for voting these
congressional members have to work their
way to a fl to the floor in a certain
timely manner to actually get their vote
in exactly that that's another reason
why these exist too because if a
congressional member is in their office
in one of these uh one of these other
buildings on the complex they would want
to have them easy access to get to the
floor to make their vote for you and
that's the point is it's your vote
they're making now you know what's
interesting is it's possible because uh
mikey or mickey cheryl i forget i don't
know how to say her name she was the one
that reported to say that she saw these
people doing that isn't there a video of
that isn't there a video of her saying
that like like
soon after january 6th i don't know if
there's a video she gave an interview
and then it was in my video i have her
walk across the capitol
uh rotunda
and say oh that's weird now here's the
other thing she works out of the
longworth house office building so
potentially
she came out of this area and saw these
people in there was like oh that's weird
or she saw people that were going into
her building or something and saying oh
that's weird so
uh there's something just to keep in
mind that you know they're all connected
and it would make sense how she was
going through and potentially going from
one building to the next and saw these
people and said
that's odd that's suspicious right
so
someone points out here a lion of judah
says there is a tram system yes there is
a trans system and and that is also
designed to help these members get to
and from the complex from outer
positions in dc where they may be
staying they may be living or or nearby
states where they live um we know that
joe biden when he was a senator
it was notorious that he would take the
amtrak into dc every day and he would
take it back out and that tram would
help connect him from the amtrak down to
dc because it's not just congressional
members it's staffers it's
not just the congressional staffers but
also the staff of the actual dc complex
and the camper complex itself so thanks
for pointing that out but you know these
are things these are things that you
wouldn't go and take historical photos
of right like i mean yeah it's you're
not going to take pictures down a
hallway of where to go to from this
building to that building i mean you
would be going to the building and maybe
taking pictures inside the office
because there might be some historical
value there but taking a picture of
where the intersection is to go to this
building or that building to get to
congressional members offices i actually
just sent you the uh the link um of her
giving the interview from this is from
one originally from 112
uh 2021 so this is a video yeah it's of
it's of cheryl talking about how she saw
unidentified lawmakers
um giving a tour on the face suspicious
visitors
okay uh bring it up here
so here is and and who is this again
this is mickey cheryl yeah yeah so this
is yeah so this is a democrat of new
jersey this is who i use in my video as
a means of saying like oh somebody was
aware and did see this as a one it
wasn't just when was this interview
given january 12th it's 12. so we're
we're yeah 12th update on the 13th so
we're talking about not even a week
right we're not even a week after the
the events on january 6.
if members of congress
are actively helping the president
overturn the election results
and so not only do i intend to see that
the president is removed and never runs
for office again and doesn't have access
to classified material
i also intend to see that those members
of congress who embedded him
those members of congress who had groups
coming through the capital that i saw on
january there she's there she's
referring to it a reconnaissance for the
next day those members of congress that
incited this violent crowd
those members of congress
that attempted to help our president
undermine our democracy
i'm going to see that they're held
accountable and i know that's kind of a
quiet video but there's there's the
political report from just a week after
um the the insurrection
where they were
where they were trying to overthrow your
vote and your government and your
constitution um and uh congresswoman
mickey cheryl there
giving her promise to you that she is
going to try to hold them accountable um
i'm going to go to the louder milk uh
trending tab here we're 20 minutes past
the second hour gabe how long is the uh
the version of what was that did you get
how long was it it is uh
six minutes okay okay i just want to
make sure because i want to get that in
um do you have the interview from doc
ready or should we maybe play that on
friday
uh we could play that on friday okay we
can play it on friday because that's
kind of green content right yeah can you
tell the folks who you did an interview
with so they
as i find where we're going to go uh
i did an interview with uh dr eric
feiglding um he is the person that first
kind of sounded the alarm about covid
back in 2020 and basically said you know
this is something that we need to take
seriously
um he you can find him on twitter um
he's always releasing new studies and
new updates as like uh throughout covid
and giving his
his expert expertise because he is a
health economist as well as an
epidemiologist he's also the co-founder
of the world world health network
um
so you know this is the person you want
to talk and listen to about covid not
your uncle at thanksgiving dinner you
know right because we've had an increase
in these cases and i think it's
important to have a
doc on um so we'll play that we'll play
that on friday because tomorrow remember
tomorrow we have the hearings during our
regular time uh noon eastern is when
we'll start our coverage of the january
6 hearing tomorrow it'll be day three
of the hearings because we had the
hearing today postponed until next week
it seems um gabe i found aoc's uh tweet
here this morning on loudermilk
and she's actually responding to him
as what she's doing um this
tweet that she's responding to was from
yesterday
barry loudermilk said breaking
the truth will always prevail as i've
said
since the gen 6 committee made their
baseless accusations about me to the
media i never gave a tour of the capitol
and this is um
i don't know who this is or who they're
again this is coming from the longwood
or longworth house office building
um from the chief of police thomas
manger so this is the united states
capitol police
um giving this statement and this is
what barry loudermilk's going off of and
the and aoc points out here said
representative laddermark released this
statement yesterday i never gave a tour
of the capitol on january 5th 2021 this
morning this footage was released dated
january 5th 2012 i my guess is that they
they probably vetted this footage like
the day where it was like that sort of
i'm sure they vetted this yeah it's
almost like if you have surveillance
equipment in a building like you have
security cameras like hey
this camera is in this building on this
floor and here's the time and here's the
date
right
it seems like it's just it seems like
it's something that's like burned into a
video you know right well here's here's
the thing about this surveillance these
are the four key areas that we pointed
out even in the surveillance footage
where
where ladder milk appears where and this
gentleman and the first one here he
appears to be taking a picture of this
stairwell which is definitely historical
documentation that a person dark
stairwell as well right he's like okay
so this is what does that sign say what
does that sign say it just says b what
do you say like
it's hard for me to tell uh
b
level b maybe i know i don't know i
don't know what this sign says it's hard
to tell in this in this footage and
again maybe we'll get some maps of from
the uh from january 6 select committee
the other the other photo that's very
significant here is up on the the top
right where he's pointing down past the
security station like he's pointing
where he's gonna go yeah and then down
there at the bottom when they go into a
security station here he he kind of
opens his arms in the video it's like
here's where you're gonna break through
to do something right i don't i don't
know like what like this is the security
area where there will be he's like this
is where you want to go when people try
to get across different buildings
when you're breaking in so you want to
make sure that you get down to the
basement here first
right right right yeah and then i'm not
real sure what the
but the aoc
is definitely calling out letter milk
here which i i like i like
i like that she's calling him out and
thank you aoc for for your tweet there
and and being on the tony michaels
podcast let's see if we have anything
else again i showed earlier the the
statement from benny tops but this
this is not something i showed earlier
the select committee saying select many
reviews
request for information from
representative barry loudermilk and a
letter to loudermilk no this is the one
i sent i believe this has the uh the
photos on it though of him actually
giving tours he's like oh benny thomas
is like oh
oh you're
you say you're not giving tours well
here is pictures yeah of you doing it
exactly yeah do you know a thing about
do you know about a thing called photos
how about this how about this thing
called moving pictures it's called
whoa whoa wait a second wait a second
moving pictures yeah
i know it's a bunch of these little
quick photos that are taken what is that
who do you speak of this i know i know
crazy technology what a time to be alive
but uh yeah it's video speaking of
videos
i do want to go to your what was that
because your what was that um it has to
do with january 6 but it doesn't have to
with a louder milk it has to do another
character in january 6 who is really
close to the president it doesn't appear
that peter namara was giving tours of
the capital but he definitely was trying
to figure out how to get people on those
tours maybe and make sure they were
touring
violently with
american flags that have spears on the
end of them that day to make sure that
his cheeto dust mobster his orange
mussolini jesus remained dictator of the
united states so tell us a little bit
about your video we'll go to break and
then we'll play the video
yeah so as some people might know peter
navarro was a white house advisor to
trump a trade advisor
and he was indicted on two counts of
contempt two charges accounts of
contempt uh against congress um for
one
uh
ignoring the subpoena that he had to
show up and give deposition and then the
second was he ignored
the request
from the january 6 committee to say hey
we need those documents that you've been
saying that uh you've been talking about
this green bay sweep on all these
different news stations and admitting to
this thing and public public uh viewing
but we want to see these documents right
and he said no i'm not going to do that
so then the january 6 committee went
over the doj and the doj yeah we're
going to charge him we're going to take
him we're going to we're going to arrest
him and bring him in now this was i
think a week and a half ago is when he
got brought in but since then there have
been developments of him trying to go on
tv and beg for money um him lying about
his incident him
uh
getting a gag order in place
um done from
the uh doj saying basically you need to
shut the [ __ ] up because you're not
adding anything to your situation
um
so yeah peter navarro he is one of the
architects of the green bay sweep the
other one with steve bannon that's
fantastic the green bays come on come on
yeah because they were like oh [ __ ] up
like we got these six states and they're
like gotta name the green bay sweep and
it's like
the annexation of puerto rico you ever
watched the little giants the movie
little giant yeah yeah yeah that at the
end when john madden's like um they're
they're going over these plays i guess
it ain't the end but it's when john
madden's on the screen is like this is
the annexation of puerto rico and it
just it reminds you that these people
are such a [ __ ] joke they're such a
[ __ ] joke
that that they're they're doing these
little kid things right they try to try
to [ __ ] subvert our democracy that's
how [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] seriously we should
take this because if these people
weren't such [ __ ] buffoons they may
have been successful here if they
weren't such [ __ ] buffoons but these
people are bone-ins [ __ ] boneheads it
is quite impressive how incompetent and
dumb these people are you know and i'll
show it in the video but it really is
just like the amount that navarro has to
be like uh i've got executive privilege
and uh i can say this stuff and
everyone's like dude people are [ __ ]
listening to what you're saying on tv so
let me let me ask you because you know
you you alluded there that navarro has
some kahunes to say this type of stuff
out in the public right yeah i wonder
because you know you see all these trump
trucks with the [ __ ] trump flags and
[ __ ] and they got the uh the the
tailgate nut sacks hanging from do you
think peter navarro drives a truck with
a big old nut attack or do you think he
drives like a prius
i i think he rides a bike i was doing
some digging what what he rides a bike
he writes well he works he he lives in
dc is that what is that what the rolled
up sleeves is about because you kind of
go on a yeah yeah i don't know if that's
what it's about because i i've seen well
i was reading an article about a divorce
he was going through and they had a
photo of him biking so i think he's more
of a a person who bikes or walks i don't
know if he actually has a car because of
his proximity
that makes sense that makes sense but if
he did drive a car if he did own a car
what do you think the car that peter
navarro would have i don't know he's
only he only wears like a buck 45 so
you know
uh i mean he said that on tv he's like
i'm 145 pounds in an interview that i
was watching
um is that why he stands in front of the
green screen to make himself look bigger
you think i think so it's all a matter
of perspective you know right i can make
this look smaller right right did i look
bigger well that that is sometimes part
of the point of having the truck with
the big trump flags and right the big
nut section i don't think he'll i mean
maybe he owns it but he doesn't drive it
oh no like he's got it all decked out
and it's it's parked in the garage like
once he got it in it can't actually get
out now so it's you think he has one of
those stupid stickers have you seen this
where they have the trump it's like
they're writing in the in the past
trump's writing in the passage on the
[ __ ] i've seen this before where they
have a decal
yeah this is i mean cult type [ __ ] it's
sculpting well everyone stick around
because we're going to play gabe's
part it's a part three it's part three
it's episode three episode three yeah
what what what was that what was that
and you're gonna want to stick through
this break because it we're going to air
re-air here and unearth the pardon
blanket
uh commercial so stick around don't go
anywhere
what was that right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
pardon blanket
making its reappearance
it's almost like gabe has a crystal ball
or something
and commercial was made a while back
the only thing that i think
he got wrong it is his list was not
quite long enough of the seditious
congress people gabe how could you have
ever guessed that louder milk no one
knew with this [ __ ] nobody knew
nobody knew who loudermilk was until
this week
oh my god oh my god but you know what
the best part about that video is you
say all the other members of congress
now you flash up you know
what looks like a brady bunch of
seditions right um but
but you never could have known that
you're like ah we'll rope in this dozen
here this doesn't hear what like why not
you know who's just larry barry
loudermilk we might as well rope in yeah
again like i didn't know i mean you know
i don't know all of the members of
congress but that was definitely a name
that was like louder milk
yeah never never even thought that was a
name you know
uh and so when the news comes out i'm
like well [ __ ] there's someone else i
gotta
pay attention to there's another one
there's another video
speaking of videos and i want to go to
your uh your episode three of what was
that
um about peter navarro here daniel let's
see if we can and it's it's a little
iffy here when we do it like this but
okay there's something it's too big to
do the other way yeah it's easy easy on
the two people oh okay whoa whoa whoa
whoa dude
on the two big talk you might uh
you might get the chat excited there uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna make this full
screen so we can see it
um here we go
episode three
what was that with the january six
hearings happening throughout june one
person who was actively trying to avoid
their questions is peter navarro he was
charged by the doj for ignoring two
subpoenas from the january 6 committee
then he filed a suit against the
committee and the doj and now in a true
trump-like drifting fashion he's on tv
begging for money for his legal fund
[Music]
former trump advisor and infomercial
salesman trying to sell you money-making
secrets peter navarro just to catch
everyone up to speed peter navarro was
one of the key authors of the plan to
overturn the result of the 2020 election
one of the others was steve bannon you
know the guy who looks like he's a mix
between dandruff and a rotten tomato
navarro was charged by the doj with two
counts for contempt of congress for his
refusal to comply with the january 6
committee the first charge was for
refusing to appear for a deposition and
the second charge was for failing to
provide information on the green bay
sweep navarro outlines the green bay
sweep in his book taking back trump's
america why we lost the white house and
how we'll win it back jesus christ that
has got to be the world record for
longest book title he stated that the
sweep was designed as the last best
chance to snatch a stolen election from
the democrats jaws of deceit navarro
said the plan was to have lawmakers on
capitol hill debate the electoral
results from six swing states in the
hope of having congress declare the
results to be in dispute navarro claimed
that president trump was on board with a
strategy and then up to 100 congressmen
were committed to executing the plan
however the plan was dependent on vice
president mike pence who opted not to
participate you know the same mike pence
that all of trump's followers wanted to
hang on january 6 during the
insurrection
awkward oh and by the way trump was
totally okay with that happening anyway
navarro has been claiming that the
january 6 committee is a sham and that
he is completely innocent despite the
fact that he goes on tv and openly
admits his involvement in trying to
overturn the election most recently he
was on ari melber show risking going
potentially to jail
not to talk to them
but you're out here
talking in public
you do realize these investigators
can hear you when you talk on tv in the
very next day navarro was arrested by
the fbi
wow i guess karma is a real thing
alright is it just me or has anyone else
noticed a theme with navarro's outfit
because every time i see him on newsmax
or fox news or ari melbourne show he's
always wearing the same outfit white
shirt rolled up sleeves and a tie
navarro reminds me of a high school
basketball coach whose team is down by
20 in the fourth quarter with three
seconds to go and in a moment of
desperation he pulls out a whiteboard
and tells us that we need to drive up
the middle and give trump the ball to
win the game this guy is an absolute
joke but actually now that i think about
it i've seen this look before he reminds
me of jim cramer you know one's a
traitor and the other
is a traitor so in the spirit of this
segment let's make a quick adjustment
much better from day one navarro has
claimed he was protected by executive
privilege well guess what
he doesn't have it so navarro then
appears to fall back on the vague
assertion that the executive privilege
here belongs to former president trump
which is not only dubious but entirely
irrelevant because our committee has not
been given any
attempted invocation of executive
privilege by donald trump navarro
reminds me of george costanza's dad just
throwing up his arms and exclaiming
executive privilege now so when navarro
addressed reporters after being indicted
by a grand jury for contempt of congress
charges he complained about how he was
treated unfairly and had to stay in john
hinckley jr cell
which is a weird thing to brag about
instead of calling me and say hey we
need you down at court
we've got a warrant for you i would have
gladly come what did they do
they intercepted me getting on the plane
and then they put me in handcuffs they
bring me here they put me in leg irons
wait what was that they intercepted me
getting on the plane and then they put
me in handcuffs they bring me here they
put me in leg irons leg irons navarro is
notorious for lying again the guy tried
to overturn the 2020 election so while
lake irons on navarro would be a great
thing to see i highly doubt they put
more than handcuffs on the guy and to
anyone out there who doubts me get me
photos of navarro and leg irons navarro
says he would have gladly shown up if
they had asked and to that i say
[ __ ] navarro was arrested at a dc
area airport while attempting to fly to
nashville to meet with former arkansas
governor mike huckabee aka thewish.com
version of ernest hemingway navarro uses
more green screen backgrounds than
hollywood blockbuster films so excuse me
if i don't believe navarro or huckabee
about flying to do an interview when he
does all of them from his basement
navarro is 100 of flight risk and then
in true navarro fashion he went on to
tucker carlson's entertainment show to
cry some more instead they went with
this shock and awe terrorist strategy
yeah let me go to the airport and then
take me with five agents like i'm a
al-qaeda terrorist maybe this is navarro
projecting and he thinks he actually is
a terrorist i i don't know i mean he did
try to return a fair and safe election
and now navarro is begging for money by
asking people to buy his book it's the
same one that i mentioned earlier with
the really long title my book taking
back trump's america i need everybody in
america to buy that book on amazon
taking back trump's america jesse
because that book is going to be my
legal defense it's on amazon this book
taking back trump's america help me
please i do not want to spend several
hundred thousand dollars on lawyers well
this is going to cost a half a million
dollars i'm looking at a half a million
dollars in legal expenses according to
some legal experts or more this could go
to a million that's going to basically
wipe out my retirement savings and i'll
be eating dog food navarro's next court
appearance is set for june 17th so who
knows maybe we'll find out more details
about who or what navarro is covering
for and hopefully the january 6
committee will have those details to
share with us or navarro just admits to
his crimes during an upcoming tv
interview because if there was anyone
who could talk themselves into a jail
sentence it's peter navarro well i'm
gabe sanchez and this has been what was
that
[Music]
well what was that what was that what
was it like i like that segment you
should do like six of those a day
yeah no i need to really get the interns
going they've been lacking man i
was like i'm going on vacation for a
couple days let's get this video out
guys i'm trying to
photoshop the interns in there you have
a few more that you're working on though
in all series yeah
everyone stay tuned um and we'll
probably
we'll probably have this on our uh
channel in and of its own but it'll
probably go to minus touch first they
like they like the what was that they
want to post it over there on their
channel uh speaking of that
guys go go over to uh youtube.com
midastouch and um subscribe to their
channel but not only that and set your
reminder for the
the hearing for tomorrow and that's
going to be super important tomorrow so
go over to minus touch
their your youtube channel and while
you're over there while you're over
there check out
some of the videos from gabe what was
that they have those over there the
other two episodes and i actually have a
playlist on our channel
what was that so make sure to sub to our
channel subscribe down below the tony
michaels podcast
uh for any updates so peter
i also uh the link is now in the chat so
if you're on facebook or twitter or or
facebook or youtube or twitch
it is now in there
uh
uh to to go and and make sure you turn
on the bell notification make sure that
you're subscribed and get ready for the
show
as it continues tomorrow so so let me
ask you um
tomorrow what what do you expect to hear
from this i mean it sounds like we're
going to have the pen story tomorrow
what do you think what do you think
we're gonna find out uh with the pen
story because we're supposed to maybe
hear from mark short which is the chief
of staff and we're supposed to hear from
this judge
um that basically told pence you can't
do that that's not a thing the thing
that they're trying to get you to do is
not a thing he even tweeted out about it
now do you remember this when the judge
tweeted this out he's a retired
prominent judge and said no this is not
a thing what do you think we're going to
see tomorrow do you think we're going to
see the evidence of that
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if we see
if we see that and as well as like
there's
you know i think every day we're going
to walk in with an expectation or like
oh these people are coming on however we
have no [ __ ] idea
what you know what juicy gossip is gonna
drop what facts are gonna drop right
like
you know they have they have kept their
cards very close to their chest and i
think it's a very smart move because you
don't want to ruin
the oh [ __ ] moment when they happen
during the hearings right and we saw
that on on on monday right you had liz
cheney
dropping different key phrases like big
massive dumps you had inebriated rudy
giuliani you know these other moments
that were like very key clippable
bite-sized moments that people have
continued to talk about and trend
um
so i could go in there and say yeah we
probably will hear these things from the
judge that say oh yeah i told them to
throw that out because i didn't believe
it it was complete [ __ ] you know uh
these these court or these cases were
brought and they had no validity no
substance to them no actual evidence um
but then i also imagine that we're going
to be like oh [ __ ] that was
because we don't actually know much of
what happened inside
the not everything was released what was
talked about inside those those court
hearings with rudy giuliani right we
just kind of most people just know the
very high level which was he went in he
presented a case the judge said show me
the evidence and he said well i don't
have it right
so
i'm i'm imagining that we will kee we
will see actual um
so footage of that of rudy footage or
the actual log or or transcript from
um the actual court appearances that
rudy and his team you know and jenna
ellis and all those other people uh try
to try to get away with right um i've
got a statement here from loudermilk um
going back to that scott mcfarland has
an alert here he says representative
loudermilk of georgia issues statement
below he says in this in the statement
to the january 6 committee is doubling
down on their smear campaign
this is [ __ ] hilarious
that these fascists are going to frame
this up as a smear campaign
um here is the statement
from loudermilk the capitol police
already put this false allegation to bed
yet the committee is undermining the
capitol police
and doubling down on their smear
campaign releasing so-called evidence of
a tour of the uh house office building
which i have already politically and
excuse me publicly addressed
as capital police confirmed he's really
clinging on to the back the blue thing
here even though they were beating well
the other the other thing i'm curious
about is like where he was in he was
like oh are these
you know in the building that he was in
right where he was like pointing around
is that technically the capital or is it
one of the adjacent buildings that are
underneath you know and he's like see i
was never inside that i was in
right i was in trying to make i was in
longworth i was in longwood guys he's
trying to make bones about showing
people where offices are right i'm
trying to fight semantics here nothing
about this visit with constituents was
suspicious other than the the actual
constitution's constituents showed up
with a [ __ ] spear on the end of a
goddamn flagpole as a weapon to i don't
know kill someone the next day to get
them is what they were saying that seems
a little sus to me the pictures show
children holding bags from the house
gift shop oh well there's children in it
gabe there's children so nothing
suspicious yeah it's almost like
insurrectionists don't have children and
because there's children these are not
insurrectionists um this false narrative
that the committee and democrats
continue to push that republicans
including myself led reconnaissance
tours is verifiably false
uh nowhere that i went with the visitors
in the house office building on january
5th were breached on january 6. who
gives a [ __ ] who cares if those office
buildings weren't breached
yeah what the [ __ ] does it matter you
were showing them down always of how to
get to places you weren't showing them
there's not i mean maybe there's video
of him showing historical
uh places inside the camera but these
people were taking pictures of
stairwells and hallways i were um that
were breached on january 6 and to my
knowledge
no one in that group was criminally
charged in relation with january 6.
now once again the committee released
this letter to the press and did not
contact me this type of behavior is
irresponsible and has real consequences
including ongoing death threats oh oh oh
louder milk here is worried about death
threats you know what else is
irresponsible giving a tour the day
before an insurrection right you know
what else you know other people that got
death threats the capitol police who
tried to die and there was something
guys you you [ __ ] boned
uh
and the line and the line where he says
no one was criminally charged oh boy
this is about to age so well oh yes oh
yes it's going to be fantastic it's
going to be fantastic and the louder
milk oh i didn't do anything even though
there's video evidence of it
hell let's go to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends i want to end the day
uh see if we can find some news um mj
had something here about the steve
bannon um
she posted something steve bannon
apparently the judge today said nope
sorry [ __ ] we're not dismissing the
charges you are still held in contempt
of congress
apparently is the um is is the word here
and of course louder milk is still
trending um we have there was another
one uh desantis is trending oh oh
desantis is turning but the one thing
that was trending was internet explorer
gabe what i know this is not politics
but i want to take just a couple minutes
here it's time to say goodbye to
internet explorer as of wednesday
microsoft will no longer support the
once dominant browser that fades away as
users
found faster less crash prone
alternatives i mean they were i mean
they did get sued as a as a monopoly or
as a monopoly for internet browsers and
saying that you know when you got office
this was years ago but when you got
office
um you know the default was internet
explorer so no one else had a chance in
terms of uh being that of a competitive
so you're saying that actually led the
way to have safari google chrome
well it wasn't i mean like safari is a
is an apple uh browser but you know you
know the ones like uh opera yeah safari
uh firefox chrome you know these are all
the ones that wanted to
you know if we're actually allowing for
competitive like a a competitive market
you have to allow these things in
and so
um
that was one where it was basically you
were gating
the software
to
to prevent others from actually having a
um
a a chance at getting their browser in
front of people by saying like oh you
you get inter explorer and that's what
the default is and that's what we're
pushing so no one else has a chance
um you know so that was the i think it
was in the eu let's see uh eu
microsoft
i miss internet explorer do you i don't
um
i mean it was the first
browser that you use you know it's like
nostalgia better well
escape was another one netscape yeah
i mean i remember all the early ones too
and all the early uh uh you know
essentially
uh database searches where you had lycos
and dog pile and you know
people still use yahoo
yeah yeah
yahoo now is more like an aggregate site
where they just kind of republish other
people's content so is betterchoice.eu
was a website created by microsoft in
march 2010 following decision in the
european union microsoft competition
case the case involved legal proceedings
by the european union against microsoft
and found that by including internet
explorer with their market dominant
windows operating system
microsoft had used its dominance to
create a
similar market position in the web
browser market the better choice.eu was
created to allow users that have not
made or were not aware of a choice to
try other browsers and thus comply with
the european commission's ruling
the other thing too is
the european union is very good about
offering choice
right and uh you mean
kind of like trust busting kind of thing
yeah yeah it's one of the problems that
we have that's one of the problems that
we have with inflation right now is we
need a little bit of trust busting going
on again right right in this case yeah
and so this is not the first time that
the european union has done something
like this
but it works out for you know looks out
and works out for the consumer to say um
you guys are not getting uh something
fairly here this is illegal what they're
doing and there's a case against it
and um
so yeah so i had to i forgot what the
website was called but what i was
talking about was real in case anyone
was like that doesn't sound right
it's some obscure it's an obscure thing
too not everyone knows about it but
that's why that's why it happened and
that's probably what led down to it i
knew i knew if i got on the internet
explorer gabe would do at least two or
three minutes on it so um
goodbye to internet explorer
live forever uh christopher uh here has
a
video of ron desantis posted he says
this is an insult to black folks somehow
i think that's how it was intended um
this is a quote from ron desantis i'm
focused on 2022 but with elon musk what
i would say is that you know
i welcome support from african americans
what can i say what the what the [ __ ] so
here's here's the story of ron desantis
this is why he's trending because
apparently elon musk has said he would
support him in a 2024 bid which only
gives you more
more [ __ ] evidence of of what elon
musk
is about here
and he's about strong white men being in
power to make sure strong white rich men
stay in power right elon musk is
absolutely he's a scared weak little
individual he's a piece of [ __ ] trash
he can't follow through on anything he
won't buy twitter trust me he's not
gonna own twitter he won't
now
he's supporting ron desantis and the
only reason why he's doing this is
because he wants to trend again he wants
relevance again because he lost it after
last week when he announced that he's
not going to buy twitter basically in so
many simple terms so this week he's he's
supporting a fascist like ron desantis
this [ __ ] let's go brandon nazi just
don't believe me believe the evidence he
said something about disney world and
his nazi supporters the let's go brandon
nazis went to disney world and started
waving their nazi flags
but here is this interview with ron
desantis where he says this don't just
take my word for it or christopher's
word for it let's listen elon musk so
what i would say um you know i'm focused
on 2022 uh but with elon musk what i
would say is you know i welcome support
from african americans what can i say
is this like his moment where this is
like the trump moment he's like my
african-american
like is that what this is like is that
his mind i don't know i mean this is ron
desantis he's clearly he's clearly
trying to say some racist ass [ __ ] that
oh there's white people from from africa
too now if people don't know
elon musk is originally from south
africa right now ron desantis is making
a black joke here clearly
um that rhonda ronda santos is saying
that elon musk is not black but he's
from africa that's why he's calling him
african-american but everyone knows what
the word african-american means in this
country now minus margie says we're
applauding you tony and gabe you're
doing a super job managing the hearings
oh thank you very much thank you so much
thank you super chat thanks for giving
us the the motivation to continue with
the hearings because i want to do every
single minute of every single one of
them and i love having all the guests
with us doing those so thank you for the
this they also updated the the times too
they moved the mornings to be afternoon
the news easier to watch thankfully you
know people keeping the west coast
people in mind you know yeah well gabe
gave eddie you no longer have to wake up
at 5 30 in the morning right right to
get ready for a 6 a.m pre-show chat no
it's not
normal time it's our normal yeah yeah
now it's normal time i can just go
longer we'll just go longer right right
i would imagine we're probably gonna
broadcast for about four hours it'd be
an hour before right two hours for the
hearing and then like an hour afterwards
so maybe about a four hour
a four hour episode in other words but
we're starting at it starts at nine it
still starts at normal time right nine
a.m it's like 9 a.m my time 12 p.m right
eastern that that's when the average
right right right right right and then
the hearing will start um right at one
uh eastern and then they'll go for two
hours and then we'll do about an hour or
so coverage after we'll go to the top of
the hour whatever the top of the hour is
with a painting i think somebody was
listening they were like oh man why this
guy's helping to cover the january 6
he's putting it out there we need to
make sure that he's rested and he looks
good on camera right and he doesn't you
know he doesn't fall asleep you know and
have to take a nap at the end of the day
yeah you don't you don't want gabe
looking sleepy or
inebriated either you know right that's
only rudy that's only rudy apparently
inebriated uh rudy giuliani back to
ronda santa's here in elon musk
it's not surprising that these two
[ __ ] idiots are bedfellows what do
you think i mean this isn't surprising
right no not at all i mean that elon
musk is like yeah woohoo ron desantis
it's
yeah the other thing too is when people
are like oh uh you know we're going to
have the first
african-american owner of twitter you
know all that stuff where people like
do you
you do you understand like he was born
in south africa he is south sure yeah
he's south african right but he's not
he's not african-american he's not black
like right like people are in in the
right here's the thing the right is
using it as a means of like oh look
we're not racist like we're we fully
support an african-american to own a
multi-billion dollar business that is
publicly that is in and of itself a
racist [ __ ] statement it is so weird
like bridgette gabriel was one of them
and then who was the other one that had
the not even a good joke these people
suck at comedy they suck at comedy
that's not even funny like that's not
even funny now all these people here let
me let me [ __ ] show it again all
these [ __ ] fascists here these let's
go brandon nazis around uh ron desantis
here watch when he says it
but with elon musk what i would say is
you know i welcome support from african
americans what can i say
he's not african-american
[Applause]
like this type of now now look look in
this if you look really close here
there's a couple black folks in this and
there's it appears to be two black women
um one on in a military uniform
camouflage to ron desantis is what would
be his left but on the right side of the
screen on the left side you have another
woman standing back here um and after
this
they don't appear to be that excited
about what he just said
right but also they're like
he wants to say that he's like oh yeah
african-americans like me or i welcome
support from african-americans meanwhile
he keeps the two african-american people
who are in the group in the back right
exactly like i'm not trying to make it a
big thing but if you're going to say
that hidden by and then you're going to
show these people in the back it's like
it's a little bit contradictory to what
you're saying right now and your dumb
ass joke
isn't actually good
right ron desantis is such a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and christopher is right
this is an insult to black folks he
again again ron desantis is trying to
dehumanize and and really
undo their skin color right because
black people aren't scared of their skin
color they're they're proud of their
skin color you should be you should be
happy with who you are that's this whole
crt thing that they're trying to guilt
people into being a race you don't get
to choose your race you should be happy
about it you should feel that you're
beautiful because of your skin and who
you are
um but that doesn't mean you have to
[ __ ] denigrate other people you know
you don't you don't have to be a bigot
towards other [ __ ] people ron
desantis you let's go brandon nazi
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i don't know i
just yeah i just i can't understand how
people aren't seeing who these people
are like ron desantis would be a great
personality on tucker carlson's uh white
privilege tonight right he would be a
great personality as a governor not so
[ __ ] much like how don't you people
understand that these people should not
be anywhere near not within a thousand
feet of [ __ ] policy
that he wouldn't make a [ __ ] joke
like that and not only think it's funny
but then everyone always said right yeah
like
you know
the only way i could see that going even
worse if there was a jeb bush moment
where nobody laughed and he was like
please clap please clap please laugh
like that's where i could say be like
jesus christ man
these people are terrible you know
you're using someone you're using a
trope of someone using them making them
a joke the butt of the joke so that you
can get a laugh and you seem like you're
a totally normal guy meanwhile you're
the one who's you know you killed people
you changed numbers for covid you tried
to ban books you want to you know you
have your don't say gay bill like this
guy is is
by and large becoming
the next fascist dictator and then he's
doing a blueprint in florida for it like
that's the whole point of what he's
trying to do in florida i think is he's
trying to lay out a blueprint of what a
fascist state would look like right
fenster here has a comment says
democrats aren't perfect by no [ __ ]
means that's true but their mistakes and
problems fall within a normal range of
human imperfection and you can't say the
same about the gqp not even close i
agree 100 percent that and and there are
there are members of the republican
party out there that fall within the
normal range of human imperfection but
they're not elected anywhere hardly and
they're not being supported by the party
and they're and because they're because
these other [ __ ] whackadies these
lunatics these goddamn let's go brandon
nazis are being supported by trump and
the like yeah so thank you minister for
the comment i 100 agree desantis and his
lackeys and the rest of the gqp are what
is wrong with his country and you see it
when you know you've got the january 6
committee trying to show what happened
on that day and showed what happened
before and after the fact to say how
these people tried to overthrow the
government and and turn over and say
that trump was the actual winner despite
the actual facts right these people say
facts over feelings but they got their
cult feelings hurt and said oh no it was
actually daddy trump and it's like sorry
dude i'm sorry i don't know how to count
you you're in the back being like all
right how many million people did we get
less than a million people like i think
we got two million more than biden is
pretty much what they thought you know
when they were counting the ballots
right um but it is a very i don't know
it's very sad but then there's you know
there are sparks of hope where you've
got
the january 6 committee you know having
the hearings and actually giving the
facts of this of what happened right i
agree i agree and i think back to the
loudermilk thing i think he's completely
[ __ ] here because i think january 6th
committee didn't release all the tape
this is just
like this was just a [ __ ] sprinkle of
the tape folks oh we're gonna get more
we're gonna get more evidence because
benny thompson would not have sent that
letter if he didn't know that there was
more evidence backing up his claims that
the january 6 select committee had and
ladder milk is really painting himself
into a corner here so
like i said earlier they've got these
clips categorized and as we've seen
they've shown
you know just
30 seconds or less of each person
that have spoken so we already saw
multiple of bill barr already right so
they've got like he talked about this he
talked about you know 2000 mules he
talked about you know telling trump that
it was not a real uh that what he wanted
to do was just you know asinine and
[ __ ] so
you know they they're they're they're
very
uh
strategic with how they're pulling out
these clips because it's discussing
specific items so as soon as something
says someone and says there's no
evidence they're going to come back and
contradict that person and prove them
with actual facts and video
so tomorrow gabe we're going to have
this coverage of this hearing go to
youtube.com slash minus touch go to
minus touch's channel on youtube
subscribe uh to the channel over there
and hit the bell notification to remind
you of tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central our coverage starts of day three
of the january six select hearing public
hearings
tomorrow again same time same place
make sure that you're listening and
until then until tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking